in meseberg in brandenburg ein guter
zeitpunkt für die klausur der
bundesregierung auch einem zeitpunkt wo
es darum ging sehr wichtige dinge
miteinander zu sprechen besprechen die
für die zukunft unseres landes aber weit
darüber hinaus von allergrößter
bedeutung sind wir haben uns mit der
sicherheitsstrategie beschäftigt die
deutschland entwickelt und haben
natürlich ganz besonders die
sicherheitslage
diskutiert und erörtert die unser land
gegenwärtig
sieht
der russische angriffskrieg auf die
ukraine ist eine zeitenwende
er bedeutet dass wieder der
imperialistische versuch gemacht wird
mit gewalt grenzen zu verschieben und
deshalb ist es richtig dass wir und alle
unsere freunde und verbündeten die
ukraine dabei unterstützen die eigene
integrität und souveränität zu
verteidigen
das ist das was wir tun aber
gleichzeitig müssen wir die veränderte
weltlage die damit verbunden ist sehr
sorgfältig wir werten das hat
konsequenzen für die zusammenarbeit in
der nato das hat konsequenzen auch für
deren erweiterung wo wir die aufnahme
von finnland und schweden sehr begrüßen
das hat konsequenzen für die rüstungs
anstrengung aller mitgliedsländer der
nato aber eben auch deutschlands ich
weise noch mal darauf hin dass wir ein
sondervermögen von 100 milliarden euro
auf den weg gebracht haben um
sicherzustellen dass wir all die
anforderung erfüllen können die für eine
sichere zukunft unseres landes
erfüllt werden müssen und wir werden
natürlich uns in der welt umschauen
müssen sicherstellen dass wir neue
freunde und alte freunde pflegen in
asien und afrika im süden amerikas um zu
verhindern dass diejenigen die
autoritäre diktaturen
voranbringen die sie führen mit ihren
politischen konzepten durchkommen und
das gilt natürlich ganz besonders für
russland und dessen gefährliche
strategie unter der so viele jetzt zu
leiden haben in der ukraine aber überall
in der welt wir haben diese fragen sehr
sorgfältig erörtert zusammen mit pedro
sanchez den ministerpräsidenten von
spanien dessen land sich ganz aktiv um
eine eigene sicherheitsstrategie bemüht
hat und haben da unsere verschiedenen
perspektiven ausgetauscht wir haben
diskutiert über unsere gemeinsamen
vorhaben in der nato und die
zusammenarbeit die unsere beiden länder
in der zukunft weiter pflegen und
fortsetzen wollen das war ein guter
austausch mit einem freund und einen
austausch mit dem regierungschef eines
landes mit dem wir eng zusammenarbeiten
und da spielen auch viele fragen eine
rolle die nicht nur militärische
sicherheit zum gegenstand haben zum
beispiel auch wie wir unsere energie
unabhängigkeit gewährleisten können wie
wir dafür sorgen können dass wir
miteinander besser vernetzt sind und in
diesem sinne haben wir uns auch sehr
dafür eingesetzt dass es möglich wird
die strom und gas und wasserstoff netze
in europa enger miteinander zu
verknüpfen
ich habe in prag die gelegenheit gehabt
über die perspektiven die diese
veränderte lage für europa mit sich
bringt zu sprechen europa ist ein
wichtiger teil unserer zukunft ist die
zukunft die wir alle miteinander haben
und wir müssen das was uns vereint die
demokratie den rechtsstaat aber auch
unser konzept seiner sozialen
marktwirtschaft in der welt behaupten
das geht nur mit einer geopolitischen
union mit einer europäischen union die
sich darum bemüht souverän und
eigenständig agieren zu können in der
komplizierter werdenden welt
neben der diskussion über die
sicherheitsfragen die sich in dieser
hinsicht ergeben haben wir natürlich
ganz besonders intensiv erörtert die
fragen die sich für die
energiesicherheit unseres landes jetzt
ergeben dazu haben wir auch mit gästen
gesprochen und auch unter anderem
sorgfältig diskutiert man kann
festhalten
wir haben früh die bedrohung erkannt die
daraus entstehen kann dass russland
seine forcieren
exporte im hinblick auf kohle öl und gas
als mittel nutzt um einfluss zu nehmen
auf die entscheidung anderer länder wir
sehen das gerade jetzt bei den
reduzierten gaslieferung und die
verträge die russland und seiner
unternehmen abgeschlossen haben nicht
eingehalten werden deshalb haben wir
begonnen all das auf den weg zu bringen
was uns in die lage versetzt gut durch
diesen winter zu kommen und wir können
jetzt und an dieser stelle sagen all die
entscheidungen die wir in den letzten
wochen und monaten getroffen haben sind
dazu geeignet dass genau dieses ziel
dass wir den winter überstehen können
als land dass wir das hinbekommen für
unsere volkswirtschaft dass wir das auch
wirklich geschaffen können wir haben
entschieden neue terminals an den
norddeutschen küsten zu bauen wir haben
entschieden in unseren gast speichern
gas ein zu speichern und haben hohe
stände erreicht wir haben entschieden
kraftwerke kohle kraftwerke wieder in
den betrieb zu nehmen wir haben jetzt
ganz aktuell entschieden dass wir in
großem tempo und unter beachtung aller
umwelt standards ist möglich machen dass
es an vielen switch gibt in den
betrieben dass sie sich unabhängig
machen können vom gas wo sie das heute
einsetzen auch da hat das
umweltministerium großartige arbeit
geleistet und wir werden weitere
entscheidungen dieser art treffen damit
uns das gelingt
zugleich wissen wir dass es nicht nur um
die frage der energieversorgung geht
dann auch um die preise deshalb werden
wir nicht nur hier aus dieser diskussion
sondern auch aus all den debatten die
wir in diesen tagen führen
entscheidungen ableiten die dazu
beitragen sollen dass die preise nicht
durch die decke schießen und dass wir
gleichzeitig die bürgerinnen und bürger
entlasten können parallel zu den
gesprächen hier aber auch noch in den
nächsten tagen wird es darum gehen ganz
sorgfältig ein sehr präzises ein sehr
maßgeschneidertes entlastungspaket für
die bürgerinnen und bürger zu entwickeln
und das und damit dazu beizutragen dass
die bürgerinnen und bürger dieses landes
aber auch die unternehmen diese
schwierige zeit durchstehen kann so dass
wir nicht nur eine ausreichende
versorgung mit energie haben sondern
auch ein wirtschaftliches und soziales
umfeld das für alle bürgerinnen bürger
und für die unternehmen gute
perspektiven beinhaltet auch wenn die
zeiten schwer sind und diese arbeit
werden wir bald abschließen
neben diesen themen die sich mit den
herausforderungen für sicherheit und
energie beschäftigen hat es hier auch
andere fragen gegeben die wir verhandelt
haben ob die für die zukunft unseres
landes von allergrößter bedeutung sind
die berufliche bildung bei eines dieser
themen das halten wir alle gemeinsam für
die wichtigste ausbildung die in
deutschland unverändert
existiert etwas das aus deutschland
kommt und dass nirgendwo in der welt in
gleicher weise
ausgebildet ist wie das bei uns der fall
ist und deshalb wollen wir alles dafür
tun dass möglichst viele junge leute
eine solche berufliche bildung ergreifen
können dass sie die chancen haben auf
einen ausbildungsplatz zu finden der zu
ihnen passt und damit eine grundlage für
ihr leben zu schaffen dass sie durch die
ganze zeit ihrer beruflich kite trägt
und umgekehrt wollen wir die unternehmen
ermuntern und dabei unterstützen
genügend angebote für die berufliche
bildung zu machen und zuletzt haben wir
uns natürlich mit dem wichtigen
zukunftsthema der digitalisierung
beschäftigt und heute auch im kabinett
dann in eine digitale strategie
beschlossen die dazu beitragen soll dass
unser land sein potenzial tatsächlich
entfaltet denn wir wollen uns nicht
abfinden mit den rankings die
international veröffentlicht werden über
den digitalisierungsgrad der
öffentlichen verwaltung der
infrastruktur in deutschland aber auch
insgesamt des ganzen
umfeldes unseres landes und wollen
vorankommen und das ist genau das was
wir uns heute fest vorgenommen haben wo
wir noch einmal sorgfältig darüber
diskutiert hat alles zusammengefasst
heißt wir haben die wichtigen themen der
sicherheit besprochen was energie was
äußere sicherheit betrifft wir haben
zukunftsfragen besprochen und wir haben
das in einer guten und sehr
konstruktiven atmosphäre miteinander
getan und auch gewissermaßen hier noch
einmal die gelegenheit genutzt unter zu
haken damit wir als regierung die
wichtigen entscheidungen vorbereiten und
treffen können die jetzt anstehen damit
es für alle bürgern und bürger eine gute
entwicklung gibt in dieser schwierigen
zeit in der wir uns jetzt wegen des
russischen angriffskrieges befinden
sehr geehrte damen und herren auch noch
ein paar grenzen gesetzt von mir
vielleicht augen sehen ja dass ich
einmal kurz persönlich anfangen das hat
nichts mit der klausurtagung zu tun und
auch nicht mit dem regierungshandeln der
bundeskanzler hatte heute morgen schon
mit herr gorbatschow gedacht der ja auch
dafür steht wie sich die beziehung
zwischen russland und europa hätten
weiterentwickeln können nun gibt es
einen weiteren politiker den der heute
verstorben ist christian ströbele ein
politiker der vielen menschen imponiert
hat mir auch wegen seiner gradlinigkeit
seinem vorbildlichen einsatz für
bürgerrechte für soziale politik und der
vielen wird
sehr geehrte damen und herren
weniger anmerkungen zudem ist der
bundeskanzler gesagt hat es ist in der
tat so dass die vorbereitung auf den
winter früh angefangen haben was die
energieversorgung situation in
deutschland angeht und weil wir so früh
angefangen haben haben wir antworten und
haben ein fortschritt erzielt der
ausschuss jetzt erlaubt gerüstet in den
winter zu gehen und ich will noch einmal
unterstreichen was der sinn dieser
ganzen übung waren nämlich die
gasversorgung auch die anderen
energieträger
immer verfügbar bereitstellen und die
gasreserven die wir angelegt haben sind
dafür da dass sie wieder aus gespeichert
werden das heißt sie werden nicht dem
markt entzogen sondern stehen dem markt
zur verfügung
zweitens werden wir darüber haben wir
schon besprochen verschiedene maßnahmen
ergreifen um die preise
nicht durch die decke gehen zu lassen es
wird daran gearbeitet
das mag die seien so zu verändern dass
bei funktionierenden markt wir brauchen
ja ein preissignal die märkte sind zu
komplex keinen keine regulierungsbehörde
entscheiden also wir brauchen das mag
signal aber die senkende effekte im
markt bei den erneuerbaren energien aber
auch bei einigen fossilen energien dass
die trotzdem weitergegeben werden können
an die verbraucher und die verbraucher
so dass wir dann einen senkenden effekt
aus dem markt heraus generieren und
nicht nur die symptome ist für niedlich
gesagt die schlimmen auswirkungen dieser
enormen preise auf die wirtschaft und
auf die verbraucher um verbraucher
korrigieren oder heilen müssen sondern
auch die ursache versuchen zu glätten
oder zu beheben
und damit bin ich ganz kurz bei der
situation der deutschen wirtschaft wir
hatten ja gestern bei der diskussion um
die energie herrn siegfried russwurm
bdi-präsidenten zum gast aber auch sonst
wissen alle kabinettsmitglieder aus
ihren vielen gesprächen mit
unternehmerinnen und unternehmern wie
wie drückt die situation für viele
produzierende betriebe sind nicht nur
die großen industrieunternehmen auf die
man immer schaut sondern viel
mittelstand viel handwerk immer da wo
energie ein wesentlicher faktor der
eigenen geschäftsmodells ist da
wenn ich sage drückt der schuh dann ist
das eine metapher die man vielleicht
früher genutzt hätte da geht teilweise
die schiere angst um den das den betrieb
weiter unter vorhalten zu können die
unterstützungsmaßnahmen haben wir kurz
geziert wichtig ist diesen betrieben
auch eine zukunft zu geben das heißt die
politischen maßnahmen so zu wählen dass
wir nicht nur den tag bestehen sondern
dass es eine klare
entwicklungsperspektive gibt alternative
energien die versorgung
des betriebs des unternehmens mit neuen
energiequellen aber auch die effizienz
zu nutzen die in der digitalisierung
liegen das ist der ökonomische sinn der
digitalisierungsstrategie die wir heute
aufgestellt haben und natürlich auch
neue technik neue entwicklung nach vorne
bringen und da greifen digitalisierung
und die energiepolitik ineinander die
förderprogramme die aus richtung die wir
heute noch einmal scharf gestellt haben
und an strategie beschlossen haben
zielgenau in diese wir müssen diesen
winter überstehen als land als
gesellschaft als ökonomie und dann die
zukunft selbstbewusst und stark zu
gestalten
ja meine damen und herren ich kann an
die letzten worte von robert habeck
anknüpfen weil das wie ich glaube diese
klausurtagung charakterisiert hat
einerseits aktuelle krisenbewältigung
andererseits durch die krise durch
schauen und sich öffnen für
zukunftsgestaltung und das stand im
zentrum unserer beratungen wir haben ein
gespräch zur situation an den
energiemärkten geführt dass mir noch
einmal ganz deutlich gemacht hat wir
brauchen ein wuchtiges paket für
entlastungen in der ganzen breite der
gesellschaft daran wird ja auch
gearbeitet zum anderen müssen wir aber
an die wurzel der probleme an und um es
ganz klar zu sagen wir haben
insbesondere an den strommärkten
spekulation
und wir haben an den strommärkten regeln
die eine art politisch gemachten rendite
autopiloten etabliert haben regeln die
dazu führen dass die steigenden
gaspreise zu extra renditen zufalls
gewinn an anderen stellen führen und
neben der entlastung müssen wir an diese
quellen steigender preise ran da haben
wir uns verständigt arbeiten da intensiv
weiter was können wir tun um vor
unsicherheit verunsicherung im markt zu
reduzieren die zur spekulation und
knappheit führt dann auf der anderen
seite die marktregeln so anzupassen dass
dieser dieser rendite autopilot
abgeschaltet wird wir haben dann weiter
geschaut in richtung der zukunftsfragen
wir reden alle über digitalisierung wir
heute hier auch wir reden über
transformation der gesellschaft aber wir
machten das passiert ja nicht von
alleine
irgendjemand muss das ja auch die wärme
pumpe installieren irgendjemand muss
auch die kabel verlegen also
digitalisierung und ökologische
transformation passiert nicht von
alleine wird nicht irgendwo bestellt
oder ein schalter umgelegt sondern das
muss realisiert werden da brauchen wir
profis in der praxis die aus der
beruflichen bildung kommen ein
schwerpunkt deshalb unserer klar zur
tagung hier wir haben sehr konkrete
maßnahmen auch in den blick genommen zum
beispiel eine exzellenzinitiative für
die berufliche bildung was steckt
dahinter die begabtenförderwerke die wir
haben mit denen akademikerinnen und
akademiker unterstützt werden die sollen
zukünftig geöffnet werden auch für
auszubildende
auch diejenigen die eine karriere in der
beruflichen bildung mit einem
ausbildungsberuf anstreben sind ja top
talente und die sollen deshalb auch
entsprechend gefördert werden das hebt
zugleich auch den stellenwert der
beruflichen bildung auf augenhöhe mit
den akademischen berufen also
exzellenzinitiative berufliche bildung
ist eine der maßnahmen die wir
beschlossen oder als auge gefasst haben
will ich sagen für die stärkung der
beruflichen bildung jan die
digitalisierung dann selbst wir haben
jetzt erstmals als bundesregierung eine
umfassende digitalisierung strategie
vorgelegt die vorgängerregierung hatte
auch so was ich sage mal das war aber
eher so eine art loseblattsammlung wo
alle ressorts zu geliefert haben und
dass das in einem kohärenten rahmen
geführt worden ist und genau dieser
mangel wurde behoben heute in der
kabinettssitzung haben wir das auch
beschlossen das ist ein schlüssel für
die digitale zukunft deutschlands ein
kernprojekt wird die digitale identität
so etwas wie ein digitaler
personalausweis sein dass 40 ein
bisschen bürokratisch an ach mensch was
macht die regierung sie will den
personalausweis digitalisieren und nennt
das digitale identität in wahrheit
öffnet das aber ein möglichkeitsraum für
neue verwaltungsdienstleistungen
und auch für neue dienstleistungen aus
der privatwirtschaft die eine
voraussetzung haben dass man nicht
rechtssicher
transparent mit datenschutz
gesichtspunkten sich identifizieren kann
also von den finanzdienstleistungen bis
zur verwaltungsdienstleistungen gibt es
eine voraussetzung digitale identität
und dieses schlüsselprojekt wollen wir
jetzt mit macht vorantreiben und dann
ist am ende auch viel leichter als heute
möglich zum beispiel eine beliebte
verwaltungsdienstleistungen
elektronisch abzubilden nämlich die
steuererklärung
da haben wir jetzt ja mit elster schon
eine ganze reihe von möglichkeiten aber
unser ziel ist dass am ende dieser
legislaturperiode
wir bei der digitalen abgabe der
steuererklärung mit nur ein beispiel zu
nennen wesentlich leichter voran gehen
können bis hin zur digitalen beleg
führung und wer weiß vielleicht sind wir
sogar irgendwann so weit dass man mit
künstlicher intelligenz sogar erkennt
was für ein beleg dass ist und der
automatisch dann in die steuererklärung
eingeführt wird also krise muss
bewältigt werden da gehen wir auch mit
großer entschiedenheit gemeinsam ran
aber darüber hinaus vergisst diese
bundesregierung die gemeinsame
zukunftsgestaltung nicht bei bildung und
digitalisierung heute zwei große weitere
meilensteine
herr minister lindner was unterscheidet
die abschaltung des rendite autopiloten
von einer über gewinn steuer herr
minister habe wie stehen sie zu dem
vorschlag der ministerpräsidenten
schwierig und söder den eine staatliche
deckelung auf den gaspreis bei 80
prozent des grundbedarfs festzusetzen
und der bundeskanzler in der grünen
fraktionsspitze heißt es sie hätten
erinnerungslücken im comic skandal und
machten ansonsten eine schlechte
performance war misburg jetzt meseberg
jetzt so etwas wie ein neuanfang und
wann genau mündete in den
koalitionsausschuss der das dritte
entlastungspaket beschließt
von links bei der sogenannten über
gewinn steuer würde mit den mitteln des
steuerrechts ein im markt angefallener
gewinn in den bundeshaushalt überführt
um damit dann zu arbeiten an solche
konzepte sind hohe rechtliche
ökonomische
und haushalterische ansprüche zu stellen
die länder in europa die solche
instrumente eingeführt haben haben in
der praxis damit ja durchaus probleme in
italien etwa gibt es bereits 20 klagen
deshalb muss man mit diesem instrument
sehr
sorgfältig in der argumentation
umgehen ist kein allheilmittel und davon
zu unterscheiden ist das strommarkt
design das gegenwärtig glaube das ist
unstrittig robert habeck hat das ja
gerade auch bereits angesprochen wo wir
gegenwärtig die paradoxe situation haben
dass der gestiegene gaspreis auch den
strompreis bestimmt derjenigen die zum
beispiel mit der sonne strom produzieren
die bezahlen aber nicht für das teure
gas erlösen aber so als hätten sie gas
einkaufen müssen und da wege zu finden
wie dies im markt design ausgeschlossen
werden kann so dass extra renditen gar
nicht entstehen unterscheidet es von dem
anderen konzept denn hier würde ja ohne
umweg des bundeshaushaltes unmittelbar
eine
entlastung der verbraucherinnen und
verbraucher sowie des gewerbes erreicht
werden bundesregierung hat ja
angekündigt dass sie sich mit diesen
fragen beschäftigt robert habeck hat das
gerade ausgeführt
erlauben sie mir ganz aus ich würde
sagen die unterstellung einzugehen die
die frage an den bundeskanzler
grundiert hat diese klausel hat noch
einmal mehr gezeigt und das hat das
letzte dreivierteljahr gezeigt und ich
glaube ich spreche für das gesamte
kabinett und ich spreche für die grünen
kabinettsmitglieder sicherlich aber auch
für die anderen kollegen und für mich
persönlich alle mal wie gut es ist dass
olaf scholz diese regierung führt mit
seiner erfahrung mit seiner umsicht mit
seiner ruhe führt ihr dieses land sicher
durch und ich bin froh dass es genau so
ist und zur fachlichen frage die
es gibt wunde drei dinge die man
unterscheiden muss erstens das was
christian lindner gerade zumindestens
umrissen hat nämlich preissenkung durch
eine veränderte struktur im markt das
also bei funktionieren des marktes denn
sonst könnten wir wahrscheinlich die
energieversorgungssicherheit nicht mehr
gewährleisten da ist das so komplex ist
sind so viele einspeise vorgänger und
auch im namen vorgänger dass man das
nicht mehr analog regulieren kann
bei funktionierendes markt ist die
günstigen effekte von bestimmten
produktion und kassierten hat darauf
hingewiesen dass sind ganz wesentlich
die erneuerbaren energien aber auch
kohle oder auch solange wir sie haben
atomkraftwerke produzieren günstiger als
gaskraftwerke die durchzurechnen an die
verbraucher das würde die strompreise
beispielsweise für die haushalte aber
auch für die unternehmen dann direkt
senken ich glaube es ist nicht besonders
geheimnisvoll wenn man sich vorstellt
dass das eine erhebliche aus
komplizierte operation ist im markt die
regeln zu verändern ohne dass der mark
umfeld also aber das ist das erste und
das wird angegangen wie jetzt schon zwei
oder drei mal gesagt und das zweite ist
die entlastung der bürgerinnen und
bürger das dritte ist
bei immer noch höheren preisen
kontingente in den haushalten zu
schaffen die die bürgerinnen und bürger
im stromkreis entlasten das das erste
was ich sagte und das zweite in einer
gewissen verbindung steht also wenn man
die preise wieder günstig machen kann
was man dann das vielleicht weniger
braucht das ist ja offensichtlich dort
würde ich jedem modell eine absage
erteilen das sagt wir deckeln oben dann
ist der preis sieht das preissignal weg
wenn das signal gegeben wird ihr könnt
gas verbrauchen und es gibt kein morgen
als gäbe es kein morgen dann haben wir
eine echte herausforderung in diesem
winter für strom gilt im grunde das
gleiche was man gut überlegen kann
energiepolitisch durchaus sinnvoll ist
im unteren bereich ein bestimmtes
kontingent
preislich zu reduzieren und in der
spitze dann also da wo die verbräuche
nach oben steigen können den markt
weiter walten zu lassen das ist zu
verstehe ich dass der vorschlag ist
jedenfalls aber nicht neu und er ist
auch seit wochen in der politischen
diskussion
zwei dinge wären dabei zu
berücksichtigen
erstens wer zahlt die differenz die
auftritt
und das sind durchaus erhebliche summen
und diese maßnahmen stehen natürlich an
den konkurrenz oder zumindestens in
einem spannungsverhältnis mit anderen
entlastungsmaßnahmen und damit verbunden
ist der zweite punkt wie sozial genau
ist diese maßnahme und bürokratisch ist
diese maßnahme und da die
energieversorger in der regel an
haushalte liefern und gar nicht wissen
wer dahinter ist ist die nicht besonders
spezifisch
trotzdem ist es ein modell das wir seit
längerem in der prüfung haben und dass
sich überhaupt nicht ausschließen will
nur es wird politisch zu entscheiden ob
die kosten und ob die sozialpolitische
entlastung so zielgenau ist dass es
besser geeignet ist als die anderen
maßnahmen die wir eben zumindestens
angerissen haben also preise über den
markt beziehungsweise direkte
unterstützung über andere systeme
die regierung arbeitet sehr gut zusammen
wie man auch hier meseberg sinnlich
erfahren konnte das war sehr
freundschaftlich und sehr konstruktiv
und das hat natürlich aufgebaut auf die
arbeit die wir seit beginn unserer
gemeinsamen zeit geleistet haben das
sind große herausforderung vor den die
regierung steht und wir haben
weitreichende entscheidungen getroffen
weitreichende entscheidungen die niemand
im letzten jahr
vorher gesehen hat dass kann man glaube
ich für das ganze land zu sagen wir
haben entschieden dass wir die
bundeswehr besser ausstatten dass wir
ein sondervermögen auf den weg bringen
wir haben dafür gesorgt dass die ukraine
militärisch unterstützt wird wir haben
sehr rechtzeitig in großer
geschwindigkeit entscheidung getroffen
die dazu beigetragen haben dass
deutschland jetzt wo der sommer zu ende
geht viel viel besser vorbereitet ist
auf einem schwierigen winter als es vor
einem jahr der fall gewesen wäre und wir
haben damit so rechtzeitig angefangen
dass die maßnahmen jetzt auch
rechtzeitig wirken hätten wir das
nämlich getan als die öffentlichen
debatten zu den themen jeweils
losgegangen waren wäre es immer schon zu
spät gewesen
ich will das nur mal am thema der
gasspeicher festmachen das ist eine
debatte da hat die regierung
entscheidung getroffen da waren noch
nicht alle sich sicher dass wir
überhaupt ein problem bekommen könnten
wir waren aber sicher dass es einen
dritten könnten haben es getan und als
eine regierung der tat wollen wir auch
weiter wirksam sein wie es mit den
beiden ersten entlastungs paketen
gemacht haben und mit dem nächsten auch
an dem arbeiten wir übrigens sehr
vertraulich sehr sorgfältig in der
regierung in die enge kopplung mit all
unseren freundinnen und freunden in der
regierungskoalition
damit es ein sehr gutes und gut
geschneidertes programm wird dass die
bürgerinnen und bürger wirklich
substanziell unterstützt und auch die
unternehmen dass sie davon nicht so viel
mitbekommen haben macht mich
professionell stolz
das werden sie dann auch rechtzeitig mit
kriegen auch das möchte ich mit
klarheit sagen
ich hätte eine nachfrage zu dem was sie
gesagt haben sie habe neben von einem
wuchtigen entlastungs paket gesprochen
vielleicht können sie das zahlenmäßig
noch etwas unterlegen in welchen
größenordnungen wir denken die ersten
beiden entlassungs pakete waren 30
milliarden sie haben davon gesprochen
dass noch spielraum im haushalt 22
gesucht werden könnte und dann 23 aber
erhebliche mittel da sind also
vielleicht können sie das etwas
präzisieren und herr habeck sie haben ja
auch zu
einsparungen aufgerufen jetzt hat der
bdi gestern gesagt und wahrscheinlich
haben sie das von den russen auch gehört
dass die einsparungen die wir jetzt
haben 21 prozent im juli ging im
vorjahreszeitraum
eher besorgniserregend sind weil die
nämlich auf
produktionseinstellung oder verlagerung
ins ausland zurückzuführen sind teilen
sie diese einschätzung und wo würden sie
sagen stehen wir bei den gas
einsparungen
herr winkel wir gehen ja sehr sorgfältig
mit dem geld der steuerzahlerinnen und
steuerzahler um und überlegen auch im
haushaltsvollzug sehr genau was können
wir leisten was können wir nicht leisten
und aus diesem grund ist davon
auszugehen dass es in diesem jahr
2022 noch spielräume geben wird man die
steuereinnahmen einerseits sieht den
haushaltsvollzug andererseits gehe ich
davon aus dass wir in einem einstelligen
milliarden-euro-bereich noch über
spielräume verfügen werden im nächsten
jahr sind die spielräume größer
da haben wir ja schon vorsorge getroffen
schon im entwurf des bundeshaushalts den
der bundes in dem das bundeskabinett
beschlossen hat haben wir vorsorge
positionen vorgesehen so dass im
nächsten jahr in der gesamtstaatlichen
wirkung also unter beteiligung der
länder wir von einem zweistelligen
milliardenbetrag ausgehen können an
entlastung für die bürgerinnen und
bürger dass es insgesamt also eine sehr
beachtliche
entlastung beziehungsweise unterstützung
für sozial schwächere
der deutsche gasverbrauch teilt sich
etwa so auf das 12 bis 15 im
strombereich zu verorten sind und haben
wir jeweils die hälfte bei privaten
verbrauchern im wesentlichen heizen und
das findet ja im winter statt ein teil
davon natürlich auch noch bei der
warmwasser zubereitung die auch im
sommer stattfindet klarerweise aber die
möglichkeiten für die privaten haushalte
in den letzten monaten gas zu sparen
waren eigentlich sehr reduziert und die
kampagne die unterstützung aber auch die
regulatorisch die wir angeschoben haben
zielt darauf dass im winter die privaten
haushalte ebenfalls ihre gas verbräuche
reduzieren um ihren beitrag zu leisten
bleibt die industrie und deswegen hat de
roos vom recht der löwenanteil der jetzt
an gas reduktion erbracht wurde und der
hat geholfen dass die speicher gefüllt
werden konnten wie sie gefüllt wurden
heute über 83 prozent
wurde von der industrie erbracht ein
teil durch
fuel switch also nutzen von anderen
möglichkeiten teilweise ölkessel die
noch vorhanden waren oder auch
kohleverstromung
teilweise auch in dem man investitionen
in alternative energien oder
effizienzmaßnahmen vorgezogen hat oder
endlich realisieren konnte ein teil in
dem die produktion gedrosselt wurde also
nicht bei 100 prozent durch ließ sondern
nur bei einem geringeren prozent anteil
aber ganz klar auch an einen anteil
daran dass produktion eingestellt wurde
und
das ist so sehr es geholfen hat
natürlich besorgniserregend weil die
zeit der ganz billigen gaspreise
also einem geschäftsmodell ein
wirtschaftsmodell das darauf von gebaut
gebaut hat dass wir aus russland auch im
weltmarkt vergleich günstigeres gas
bekommen als andere regionen so schnell
nicht wieder kommen wird und vielleicht
auch gar nicht wiederkommen wird
deswegen hat der bus vorm recht diese
nachricht ist keine gute nachricht
sie hilft aber sie ist keine gute
nachricht weil sie jeweils in den
betroffenen industriezweigen bedeuten
kann dass dort ein strukturwandel und
wenn es unter großen druck vor läuft
auch ein strukturbruch passieren kann
wir antworten darauf auch das ist teil
der klausurtagung gewesen indem wir die
arbeitspolitische maßnahmen die bei
corona eingeführt wurden
kurzarbeitergeld fortführen werden und
dass wir die industrien unterstützen
alternative
produktionsform auch andere alternative
geschäftsmodelle zu entwickeln
denn die annahme dass die gasversorgung
welt mit dem günstigeren preisen von vor
februar
2022 wieder zurückkommt die kann ja
keiner ernsthaft hegen also brauchen wir
unterstützung für die zukunft ich habe
es vorhin angedeutet und unterstützung
für die menschen in diesen betrieben
und die brauchen wir nicht nur wer die
regierung wir bringen die
vielen dank herr bundeskanzler sie haben
sich ja heute morgen schon zum tod von
michael gorbatschow geäußert und seine
bedeutung für deutschland gewürdigt mich
würde interessieren ob sie sich
vorstellen können oder wünschen würden
nach moskau reisen zu können zu seiner
beisetzung oder zu einer trauerfeier und
glauben sie dass das überhaupt für
internationale gäste möglich sein wird
angesichts des angriffskriegs auf die
ukraine und eine nachfrage zum
entlastungspaket vielleicht an alle drei
die ampel koalition hatte sich eine
koalitionsverhandlung auch vorgenommen
wichtige entscheidungen nicht mehr in
nachtsitzungen zu treffen und ohne
durchstechereien da würde mich
interessieren ob musik glauben dass sie
ihnen das beim entlastungspaket auch
gelingen wird denn jetzt wahrscheinlich
wird die entscheidung ja an einem
koalitionsausschuss in den nächsten
tagen fallen naja bisher es ist ohne
nachtsitzung gegangen und auch ohne
durchstechereien das muss man sehr klar
dazu sagen deshalb kann man die prognose
machen wird wohl wieder klappen dass das
auch bis zum ende so bleibt und wir
arbeiten wirklich intensiv daran das
habe ich vorhin schon gesagt und betont
damit ist es jetzt nicht der ort oder
der zeitpunkt über reisen zu reden aber
vielleicht darf ich ihre frage für eine
bemerkung nutzen ich hoffe dass der
russische staat seinen früheren staats
und regierungschefs die ehre erweist ihm
gebührt
ich habe noch eine frage zum
entlastungspaket die sich in erster
linie finanzminister richtet vielleicht
auch an den bundeskanzler der vorschlag
auf den sich die meisten leute
eigentlich einigen können und in die
meisten befürworten wäre ja eine
einmalzahlung an die bürger eventuell
bis zu einer gewissen einkommensgrenze
das ist ja nun seit ewigkeiten im
gespräch so was eben dieses stand schon
im koalitionsvertrag für den co2 preis
und die antwort der regierung ist immer
nur das geht nicht weil wir den bürgern
kein geld überweisen können weil wir
keine kontonummern haben mich würde
interessieren warum ist das so schwierig
und bestätigend einer aussicht dass sich
daran noch irgendetwas ändert oder haben
sie das schon komplett aufgegeben danke
also herr bollmann die absicht ist klar
das ist ein vorhaben des
koalitionsvertrages dass wir in der lage
sein wollen einnahmen aus der co2
bepreisung an die menschen zurückzugeben
das ist nicht nur ein gebot
sozialer gerechtigkeit sondern wäre auch
ein echter anreiz individuell den co2
fußabdruck zu verkleinern
das ist aber ein sehr voraussetzung
volles vorhaben herr bollmann es hört
sich so einfach an oder man auch ich
vielleicht von einem jahr sagen wir mal
eben also das ist komplizierter die
rechtlichen voraussetzungen schaffen wir
jetzt in dem die möglichkeit der
verbindung steuernummer und iban
geschaffen wird das kommt in die
abgabenordnung die
rechtsetzung läuft das kriegen wir jetzt
in kürze hin aber dann beginnt die
technische umsetzung dann muss nämlich
bahn
bei der behörde die s machten
entscheidung muss noch getroffen werden
müssen steuernummer und iban
zusammengebracht werden jetzt sind wir
aber ein paar deutsche sind ein paar
die man einsammeln muss ein paar sind
auch schon vorhanden also bei den
sozialversicherungen und
beim finanzamt und das zu integrieren
das dauert nach den angaben der
expertinnen und experten in meinem haus
also bundeszentralamt für steuern jetzt
insbesondere das dauert mal eben 18
monate diese ganzen daten zusammen zu
bauen es geht aber noch weiter herr
bollmann nach den mir vorliegenden
zahlen wäre die öffentliche verwaltung
gegenwärtig mit ihrer it nur in der lage
hunderttausend überweisungen am tag
vorzunehmen überlegen sie mal wie viel
deutsche wir sind wie lange braucht das
denn dann bis 100000 überweisungen pro
tag und dann millionen leute also
verstehen sie ist nicht so einfach dass
man sagen kann wir drücken auf den knopf
koalitionsausschuss beschließt geld ist
im haushalt da werden wir schnell los zu
ihrer frage wir haben ja in diesem jahr
andere möglichkeiten für einmalzahlungen
genutzt energiepreis pauschale
beispielsweise und der bundeskanzler hat
ja bei verschiedenen gelegenheiten schon
zum ausdruck gebracht dass er bei
rentnerinnen und rentnern auch im winter
einen handlungsbedarf sieht ich finde
diese einschätzung des bundeskanzlers
nachvollziehbar und dafür würde es
technisch gangbare wege geben
ja ich glaube das muss jetzt hier nicht
weiter erörtert werden wir arbeiten an
einem großen bauwerk und die architektur
dieses bauwerks hängt eben von allen
einzelteilen ab die aber nur zusammen
eine gute konstruktionen ergeben und
daran sind wir zu gange ist eben schon
gesagt worden dass wir bestimmte dinge
gemacht haben nur ein kleiner hinweis im
september ist auch der zeitpunkt in dem
die energiepreise richtig premier die
bürgerinnen und bürger erreicht richtig
ich hätte zunächst eine frage an herrn
minister lindner die reform des
strommarkt designs ist ja eigentlich
langwierig und eigentlich müsste man das
europapolitisch auch angehen jetzt wird
ja im haus von minister habe kein
konzept erarbeitet um zum beispiel bei
den strommarkt bei braunkohle
kraftwerken oder windenergieanlagen oder
solaranlagen die hohen gewinne teilweise
neu über 900 euro die megawattstunde im
moment bei den preisen abzuschöpfen wäre
das für sie für die übergangsphase ein
modell dieses geld abzuschöpfen um auch
entlastungen zu finanzieren bis man zu
einem neuen strommarkt design gekommen
ist und an dem bundeskanzler und
minister habeck gerichtet die frage herr
lin hat sich jetzt dafür ausgesprochen
dass man bundesweit das neun euro ticket
in anderer form fortführen kann
könnte das teil des neuen pakets sein
und in welcher größenordnung könnte man
da planen also 49 eur 69 euro erlitten
hat das ja quasi den ländern
anheimgestellt aber vielleicht haben die
preisvorstellung danke also in ihrer
frage sind aber schon sehr viele
feststellungen
also zum strommarkt wird er robert
habeck berichten und nichtig aber sie
haben in ihrer frage die feststellung
gehabt das würde alles sehr lange dauern
ich habe nur gelesen dass ursula von der
leyen und die europäische kommission das
jetzt gerade ganz oben auf die
tagesordnung genommen haben aber dazu
der robert und zum neuen euro- nachfolge
ticket habe ich ja zunächst mal nur
gesagt und der olaf scholz sagt dann als
bundeskanzler im gesamtzusammenhang was
ich habe nur gesagt der volker wissing
hat
etwas bahnbrechendes erreicht nämlich
über drei monate den tarifdschungel in
deutschland zu lichten und
das hat den ganzen öpnv hat alles für
viele attraktiver gemacht weil du kaufst
in berlin das ticket und steigt in
münchen auch ein und das ist der riesen
vorteil gewesen und er hat mich davon
überzeugt dass er mit einem bruchteil
der bundesmittel die wir für
das neue euro ticket eingesetzt haben
oder im jahr einsetzen würden dass er
mit einem bruchteil der summe in der
lage wäre so etwas bundesweit zu
realisieren wenn die länder mitmachen
und also an einem bruchteil von 14
milliarden das würde neun euro
bundesweit ein jahr kosten mit einem
bruchteil so eine innovation bei den
öffis zu erreichen da kann man nicht
nein sagt
in der tat ist es so dass als wir das
neun euro ticket vorgestellt haben ganz
viele und wenn da eine oder die andere
sich selbst noch mal nach google auch
hier einige gesagt haben was ist denn
das für eine idee und nun wo das fast
drei monate lang gewirkt hat haben alle
den eindruck da ist viel innovatives
dabei gewesen zu den innovationen gehört
das was christian linder eben
vorgestellt hat dazu gehört auch die
einfachheit und deshalb ist der
verkehrsminister in der tat ja lange
daran sich zu überlegen was kann man da
machen aber nochmal über das
gesamtkonzept dass wir miteinander
vereinbaren werden sprechen wir wenn es
fertig ist das glaube ich höre zum guten
hausbau dazu und das wollen wir gerne
auch so machen ich will gerne noch mal
unterstreichen dass die
bewegung in europa jetzt ganz massives
das kann nicht berichten aus vielen
kontakten die ich mit europäischen
staats und regierungschefs hatte die
sagen so geht das nicht weiter
der schmerz den wir haben das hier
gewinne erzielt werden die niemand
richtig finden kann den haben alle
anderen auch also das
billig strom produziert wird und man von
der tatsache profitiert dass es eine
kleine begrenzte menge von kraftwerken
gibt die mit gas strom produzieren und
dass wir das nicht einfach auf sich
beruhen lassen das ist offensichtlich
ich habe auch mit dem ratspräsidenten
dem tschechischen ministerpräsidenten
darüber gesprochen wer will dass auch
auf seine tagesordnung setzen und da
druck machen dass das schnell geht ich
glaube da werden wir schnelle
veränderungen sehen schneller als sie
manchmal mit dem blick nach brüssel
verbunden sind
danke herr bundeskanzler eine frage zum
thema entschädigung für die opfer des
münchner olympia attentat da gibt es
berichte oder meldungen über eine
einigung bzw eine bevorstehende einigung
können sie was dazu sagen die dem fall
gegebenenfalls auch zu den inhalten und
der lindner ein weiterer versuch in eine
summe zu entlocken die höhe des
bürgergeldes soll im september
feststehen können sie dazu was sagen
danke
das ist so dass wir sehr gute sehr
vertrauliche gespräche haben was die
frage betrifft wie wir uns
verhalten zu dem schrecklichen attentat
im anschlag der da stattgefunden hat bei
den olympischen spielen und so wie er
auch wie wir auch unserer verantwortung
gerecht werden ja
sind traurig und
haben uns auch entschuldigt und wollen
und werden das auch tun aber es geht
eben auch darum eine gute lösung zu
finden aber mehr kann man jetzt
klugerweise nicht sagen
und das gilt auch für das bürgergeld der
bundeskanzler hat bei verschiedenen
gelegenheiten gesagt niemand wird
alleine gelassen in dieser krise und das
wird sie auch am bürgergeld zeigen aber
man kann nichts konkretes sagen
der bundeskanzlerin noch eine nachfrage
zu den entschädigungen sollte es jetzt
zu einer einigung kommen ist ihnen das
thema so wichtig dass sie an den
gedenkfeiern für die opfer des olympia
attentat vielleicht selber auch
teilnehmen würden neben dem
bundespräsidenten und herr linden
ansieht die frage es hat ja in den
vergangenen tagen erhebliche
friktionen zwischen
spd und grünen auch gegeben sie haben
sich immer so ein bisschen als
außenseiter in der koalition beschrieben
als nicht linke partei hilft es der fdp
jetzt zu sehen dass auch die anderen mal
streiten könnte das vielleicht
vielleicht für das koalitionsklima sogar
förderlich sein danke
alles im zusammenhang mit
olympia soll im zusammenhang gesagt
werden
herr besser zu ihrer atmosphärischen
frage also wir haben hier im
bundeskabinett nicht nur heute sondern
das machen wir sonst auch kollegial und
gut zusammengearbeitet
das zeigt sich daran dass wir ergebnisse
miteinander erreichen
das ist da mal ab und an öffentlichen
austausch gibt es unvermeidlich in der
politik und dass die fdp und spd und die
grünen jeweils eigenständige parteien
mit eigenständigen politischen profil
sind ja das wird auch niemanden
überraschen und von daher also ich sehe
das mit einer gewissen gelassenheit
entscheidend ist dass die ergebnisse
überzeugen die wir ja in kürze auch
wieder vorlegen
herr bundeskanzler eine frage noch zur
der änderung des strommarkt designs sie
sagten gerade es könnte schneller gehen
als man das von brüssel gewohnt sei
können sie das ein bisschen genauer
sagen also soll die änderung dieser
anstreben schon in diesem jahr wirksam
werden wirksamkeit zeigen auch für die
verbraucher oder muss man länger warten
und auch noch mal zurückgekommen auf die
entlastung sie haben von einem haus
gesprochen dass sie gerade bauen wollen
da sie ja jetzt in den nächsten tagen
offenbar das haus schlüsselfertig sein
soll vielleicht können sie wenigstens
die grundzüge nennen die auf jeden fall
darin vorkommen werden und die in der
koalition nicht mehr umstritten sind
also schon dank für ihre erneute
nachfrage zu diesem thema und immerhin
zeigt es uns dreien und ich glaube noch
vielen anderen dass es richtig ist dass
wir so intensiv daran arbeiten und dass
wir uns auch in festem zeitplan
vorgenommen haben in dem wir uns
befinden also doch jetzt schnell die
entsprechenden ergebnisse
präsentieren zu können und zwar solide
und ordentlich erarbeitet mehr macht
aber jetzt in der tat keinen sinn zu
sagen weil das werden wir dann tun wenn
das sichtbar ist ein paar punkte sind
genannt worden in der öffentlichkeit von
mir schon und darauf hat christian
lindner verwiesen aber ich kann ja auch
nur noch mal sagen wir haben ja zum
beispiel im zusammenhang mit der juniper
rettung ja bereits ein paar kriterien
genannt und die geltenden verändert und
gehen wir auch ein paar hinweise was
unter anderem eine rolle spielen wird
bei dem was wir beschließen wollen und
im hinblick auf europa können wir jetzt
nur sagen dass der wille besteht schnell
zu handeln das ist erstmal richtig und
auch bemerkenswert weil das doch bisher
sehr zäh war aber mein eindruck ist
während das früher noch eine sehr
skeptische debatte war ob das wirklich
sinn macht an das strommarkt design
ranzugehen ist die skepsis weg und alle
wollen dass und jetzt müssen wir es nur
noch hinkriegen den prozess wie wir das
was wir gemeinsam richtig finden
identifizieren nicht sich in die länge
ziehen zu lassen aber auch da ist der
druck so groß dass sich wirklich sehr
zuversichtlich bin dass es schnell geht
schön lang